justement le verrez parole alors là
votre héros je veux dire c'est vraiment
le sentiment le plus original de tous
ceux qui sont là ça ce qui s'appelle
concombre masqué comment vous est il
venu à l'esprit de prendre un concombre
comme héros on va céder pour être
original justement parce que à l'époque
où j'ai commencé à dessiner il y avait
beaucoup d'animaux fabuleux il y avait
le marché puis l'ami il y avait le
copyright de forest et ça me plaisait
beaucoup et je me suis dit bon il faut
que je trouve quelque chose mais
pourquoi un animal pourquoi pas un
légume
c'est original et pourquoi le masque est
masquée parce que ça sera le zorro des
potagers c'est un héros c'est vraiment
un héros ou alors un héros ces masques
je me suis demandé si votre papa n'était
pas vendeur de légumes et qu'il est
tombé sous une fausse identité
ce qui expliquerait peut-être cette non
non on m'envoie paris et russe
votre wii ah bon il est dans la bd de
monsieur dimitri oui et en russie il ya
le légume nationale c'est de le logo
lietz et le bol au sol c'est le
concombre salle et donc les rapports il
va y avoir quelque chose
bon alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il
arrive à votre complètement le portrait
psychologique de votre concombre masqué
à silence est difficile à définir parce
que moi ça fait ça fait quinze ans que
j'essaie de savoir exactement ce que
c'est mais je vais aventure qu'elle est
née 60 ans 60 va pas et il a combien de
volume derrière lui au très peu parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup d' aventure
je n'ai pas fait que décider il y en a
trois ou quatre vous voyez que votre
concombre votre concombre ne se vend pas
beaucoup et que année là j'ai eu
d'autres passions
des patients journalistique j'ai fondé
des journaux qui ont fait faillite
d'autres qui vont vers le succès enfin
je me suis j'aime beaucoup aussi
m'occuper de jours non mais ce qu'au
départ c'est un héros pour les enfants
pour les adultes
alors là problème pour répondre à ces
questions et à l'époque à l'époque en 65
effectivement j'ai dessiné dans pif dans
l'aval de pif
donc c'est présent fin c'était pour les
enfants mais en fait c'est les adultes
qui le lisent est déjà à l'époque
c'était les vendeurs de l'huma qui vont
utiliser ça et qui adore les seins en
cachette ou alors les très jeunes
enfants
mais entre les deux les gens ne
comprenaient pas à l'époque j'ai trouvé
ça trop délirant trop absurde
comprennent pas ou beaucoup
mais bon et puis maintenant je crois que
les gens sont habitués je prend alors le
portrait psychologique vous avez pas
répondu à mes questions moi je le trouve
dynamique sympathie courage essayé j'ai
essayé une fois de le définir dans un
album qui s'appelle comment devenir
maîtres du monde
parce que comme c'est un personnage qui
vit dans un désert qui vit dans une
maison qui s'appelle un cactus blockhaus
donc puis enfermé une drôle d'alluré
très très mauvais caractère qui rejette
tout le monde qui qui a des éléphants
qui se balade dans le grenier qui joue
au bol ingrid hayes des îles à leur
mégalomane complètement fou alors je me
suis dit
bon là son seul dessein son sol destin
c'est de devenir maîtres du monde
alors j'ai un raconter une histoire sur
ça et je me suis aperçu à ce moment là
que le seul problème du maître du monde
c'est d'arriver à démissionner parce que
pour devenir maître du monde c'est très
simple mais quand on est maître du monde
pour démissionner c'est très très
difficile parce que personne ne veut
vous démissionnez il en faut un il est
dément ce garçon je remarque est subtile
quatrième à la poursuite du brouch clag
mordoré oui d'ailleurs par parenthèse
sur le titre il ya bouche clag avec un
jet à la faim et à l'intérieur du volume
cge
ah oui mais ça c'est parce que le wifi
pour la couverture alors que les lettres
soit alors là il ya des il ya des
personnages il ya le grand module de là
c'est la planète be good as
il ya le grand pat a pas de potatoes à
tête aux heures c'est dément c'est oui
c'est oui c'est à dire qu'en fait je ne
connais pas bien le personnage parce que
je construis mes histoires d'après des
rêves que je fais ou des jeux de mots je
trouve un jeu de mots je me dis il faut
faire l'histoire dessus comme par
exemple un jour le concombre d'or chez
lui à robinet qui fuit et qui
l'empêchent de dormir alors ils courent
après le robinet pour le fermer et le
robinet fuit forcément au robinet qui
fuit ça fuit ah oui et alors il ya un
escargot qui dit au concombre si tu veux
rattraper un robinet qui fuit il va
falloir que tu t'entraînes à la course
parce que avant donc toutes les
histoires sont bâtis comme ça sur des
jeux de mots je ne sais pas du tout où
je vais en commençant alors c'est vrai
qu'il a une invention langage et qui est
intéressant parce que j'arrive dont il
ya des mots qui sont très jolies et
brouch lac daniel goury fourie type il
est complètement singles i phone et le
type débat divulgué intervi douillet
pâteuse et il ya une erreur quand même
ces enfers et pataphysique hacker qui
est un juron québec est une erreur
totale
ah bon vous n'avez aucune idée de
l'enfer mon vieux vélo trial et des deux
qui ne veulent pas là c'est vrai qu'à la
fin il s'écrit comme sas avait été
choqué et membre du collège de
pataphysique scheer et jean monsieur
vous êtes très genre mais bon vous avez
été non vérité vous êtes curieux parce
qu'ils en primo pataphysique dans sa bd
bah oui mais avec l'enfer non mais même
si j'ai employé le ciel vous auriez pt3
qu'il l'a il employait il n'a pas
employé à bon escient je t'en fais pas
ta physique tu dois ya beaucoup d'
absurde c'est très drôle et très drôle
des aventures du combat chez jallet
préféré à l'oreille au début d'ailleurs
les aventures du concombre masqué ah bon
oui c'est peut-être maintenant parce que
je m'habitue à ça si tu es toujours là
même concombres oui ou non mais là il a
des copains il a eu un copain qui
s'appelle s'échouera choix canard aussi
qu'elles sont la canarde je n'ai pas le
nombre
bayer n'a pas de nom mais le dernier
album je les fais un peu un peu moins
absurde je me suis parti d'un conte
russe que j'ai adapté
alors le grand module en fait c'est le
roi méchant
braunschweig c'est le génie des forêts
qui attrapent des fourrures d'animaux
bizarres et il ya le fils du roi qui
intervient j'ai même essayé de dessiner
réaliste giro en suivant tel stress est
malemenée natoire y aura 10 c'est bien
[Musique]